[Music]
these are nachos that golden crispy
chips gooey melted cheese mounds of
toppings galore
they are delicious they're named after a
man a man named nacho
this was Ignacio Anaya known to friends
and foes alike as nacho in 1943 Ignacio
was a Maitre D' at this restaurant the
old victory club in Piedras Negras
Mexico a border town of jalapenos
through from the Eagle Pass Texas home
of Fort Duncan an army base filled with
military men and families one day a
group of Army wives crossed the border
they shopped they got hungry they went
to the victory club the chef wasn't
there but Ignacio Maitre D' didn't want
to turn the woman away so he sprang into
action
grabbing tortillas shredded cheddar
cheese and jalapenos
he put his creation into the up
pensively he served it to the army wives
that he loved returning to Texas they
spread the e/l vangelia del nacho the
gospel of the nacho nacho specialis
became so adored and renowned Ignacio
opened up his own restaurant the
creatively named nachos restaurant a
[Music]
the creation of the potato chip is a
rather snarky surprising an
idiosyncratic story when french fries
made their way to America they soon
became a restaurant mainstay many
restaurants serve fries as their
signature dish believe it or not they
were once considered very hoity-toity in
1853 George Crum was a chef at the
moon's lake house in Saratoga Springs
New York their signature dish was none
other than moons fried potatoes or as
the aristocrats would say potatoes
served in the French manner one day just
like any other a customer some believed
to have been Cornelius Vanderbilt
himself ordered fries upon being served
Cornelius scoffed and sent them back he
deemed the fries soggy and not crispy
enough this insanity intended a few more
times until Crum lost it I mean he
really lost it he fired back cutting the
potatoes paper-thin and frying them up
you see back in 1853 eating with your
hands was a major faux pas making crumbs
revenge even more diabolical by cutting
the potatoes paper-thin there would be
no way that Cornelius could use his fork
forcing him to use his hands crumbs plan
backfired
he kind of as the patrons dug in with
both hands and loved them Saratoga chips
were born they became a Saratoga dining
staple soon thereafter they took the
world by storm Crum himself even opened
his own restaurant
with baskets of chips displayed on each
and every table
[Music]
[Music]
there's more to sight than just being
able to see the crowd you can definitely
feel the atmosphere there's a vibe in
the air there's the energy in the air
there's a sound it's amazing to hear the
fans especially when we were on the
tunnel
I'm Jake Wilson I'm the long snapper of
the University of Southern California
Trojans
I'm completely blind I have no eyes I
went in to play football with the
mentality that I had nothing to lose
longtime ian is an art you definitely
have the mechanics but a lot of it just
feel feeling that ball come off your
fingertips in a spiral how hard you're
throwing it you know where you're
releasing it just kind of getting that
velocity and in that in the accuracy
life's unfair
football's unfair but at the same time
it's up to you of how far you want to
take yourself when I was eight months
old I was diagnosed with a rare form of
eye cancer called retinal blastoma
when the doctors found my cancer it was
completely taken over my left eye so
they almost immediately removed my left
eye from there on you know just a cycle
of you know the cancer coming back they
would fight out with treatments doctors
finally said listen we've pretty much
exhausted all all treatment options
that's safer option is just you know the
removal of the eye growing up in the
2000s where coach Carroll was so
dominant with USC it was hard not to be
a USC fan I always loved football I
continued to play flag football my
eighth grade year after losing my sight
it was not anything close tackle
football as I entered high school I
decided not to play football for my
freshman and sophomore year it really
was something that I didn't think I
could do but eventually my love of the
game really overcame any doubts and I
learned how to be an asset
money I just love the camaraderie of
football I love being part of the team
love putting on you know just the pads
and the jersey and stuff and being part
of the team what was enough just that to
get me to try
[Music]
[Music]
how many people have the opportunity to
be a world champion at anything we have
the opportunity to do something that no
one else does this doesn't played
anywhere else in the world so yeah like
it's serious like we want to win
[Music]
we're gonna watch unicycle football it's
football on unicycles we stick the NFL
rules as closely as possible says
there's a few exceptions goes riding a
unicycle we play five on five two
receivers a blocker a center and a
quarterback everything has to be done on
a wheel the second your foot touches the
ground you're done
HT plays 14 games was 56 regular season
games total the wildcard playoffs and
playoffs and then the stupid ball every
Sunday some people have been doing this
for 10 years now my team the black outs
were undefeated and we're gonna be
playing the reigning champs the herons
bulldoze them over this game is very
important because we want to maintain
our undefeated status leading up to the
Super Bowl
they're definitely gunning for us
they're practicing just for us
I think that a lot of times people come
to this game what shocks them is the
level of play we're crashing at 15 miles
an hour it's not a joke
some people get seriously injured most
people learn to ride unicycle because
they came and witnessed this event and
like I've got to do this once you catch
that first ball once you get that first
brush once you hear the crowd scream
your name once that's a feeling you
can't get anywhere else that's almost
like a religion church to us here
there's passion you know it's a show
it's a spectacle it's also a sport I've
cherished every minute of it it's you
can't replace it anything there's
nothing else like it at all
you
when you see the players get the ball in
their home for the first time it's a
cross between intrigue and excitement
it's great to see him try and bounce the
ball and just see it actually bounce
away
it can make the best of people look
really really silly the number one sport
in Australia is Australian rules
football it's basically a cross between
rugby and soccer and the fans go crazy
for it there's one problem they don't
have enough tall people so what do they
do they come to the states this combines
the u.s. AFL combine and we started this
four years ago basically in a search for
four guys six foot seven and above and
these tall American athletes they don't
really need to know a lot about
Australia
the home of the kangaroos I think I know
a lot of kangaroos I hit a lot about
kangaroos and spiders and snakes in
selecting these athletes we
predominantly look for guys that are
hungry most of the participants
predominantly come from basketball the
concept of basketball in terms of the
athlete being in traffic and having
spatial awareness and those sorts of
things is really transferable to our
game which is good news because less
than 2% of college basketball players
will make it to the pros the Australian
Football League gives them another
chance to live out their dreams of being
a pro athlete most of the participants
are quite shocked when they say the game
for the first time the question is what
are the athletes think of all this well
I got to come with why I thought it was
fake actually I thought it was a scam
first thing I thought that it was a scam
I thought it was a contact in the wrong
person absolutely Woody's Australian
football skepticism aside how do you
teach these guys a game they never even
heard of before
so the combine kicks off in the early
piece with a physical testing and then
start to build into the skills the
basics of hand boiling the ability to
see what they like with their hands then
we can start to get into the more
competitive stuff where they might crash
& bash into each other which they love
that this is Mason Cox he played
basketball at Oklahoma State two years
ago he was just like one of these guys
on the combine now he's playing
professionally in Australia they can be
one of the 22 superstars out there on an
AFL team it's a fantastic opportunity
for these guys to continue their
professional career
ok squad listen up there's more than one
way to end a game a sports ball
there's the walk-off home run the
sudden-death goal the buzzer beater but
within the adrenaline addled psyche of
the American sports fan can any of them
produce a heart attack like a successful
L Mary pass don't answer that
it's rhetorical why our Hail Marys
special because they're unicorns since
1975 there's only been 28 of them in
professional football why because
they're almost impossible to get right
to complete a Hail Mary the past needs
to be long like thrown from midfield
long with little or no time remaining on
the clock and you need to be losing and
the past must lead to a touchdown that
results in at least a tie but preferably
a win that is a Hail Mary most
quarterbacks are likelier to marry a
supermodel than to throw a successful L
Mary in their career Exhibit A Tom Brady
so how did this play which practically
requires an act of God come to pass see
what I did there easy with a prayer
[Music]
tell Mary full of grace the Lord is with
thee so it's December 28 1975 50 yards
from the endzone but needing the
touchdown to win Cowboys quarterback and
devout Catholic Roger Staubach whispers
a Hail Mary to himself hail Mary full of
grace the Lord is with thee
and launches a desperation pass to
receive a Drew Pearson the Cowboys win
and the Hail Mary is christened
forevermore any questions good now go
win me some ballgames